pau
et
souvenez vous de ces images ou les avait
vus au cinéma à la télévision
l'été 1955 ça ne vous dit rien le
championnat du monde de vitesse sur rail
avec record homologué de 331 km à
l'heure
le monde entier a parlé de la petite cc
alstom la loco la plus vite du monde
ce matin-là on m'avait tout vers un
chemin triomphal entre mont de marsan et
bordeaux
douze ans déjà et mon record n'a jamais
été battu et je roule toujours et j'ai
déjà fait des milliers de kilomètres
souvent au terme d'un voyage je pense je
pense à l'endroit où je suis né à cet
immense usine alstom qui s'étend sur 134
hectares au coeur de belfort
à cette ville dans la ville avec ses
rues ses places ses quartiers huit mille
personnes travaillent là dans le temps
on l'appelle la fabrique est l'une de
mes aïeuls qui fut construit d'ici en
1875 m'a raconté qu'à cette époque-là
belfort n'était qu'un gros bourg qu'un
gros bourg qui s'est mis à grandir à
mesure que se développe l usine
je suis étonné pourquoi belfort
patiemment ma grand mère m'a expliqué
qu'après la guerre de 1870 la société
alsacienne de mulhouse pour ne pas être
prochaine décida de s'installer à
belfort en france
au fil des années la scm est devenue
alstom on y fabrique toujours des
locomotives mais aussi de puissants
matériel électrique et mécanique qui
sont exportées dans le monde entier
à nous faire un tour dans les bureaux
tiens la télévision c'est un reportage
que dit ou deux mois ci et la bb les
sigles bb et cc ne signifie pas comme on
pourrait le croire
les initiales de brigitte bardot de
claudia cardinale
il s'agit simplement de définir le
nombre d'essieux que comporte la
locomotive une bb comporte quatre
essieux lcc en comporte 6 combien de
personnes travaillent à la traction pour
l'ensemble de la société
il faut compter à peu près 3000
personnes qui concourent à la
fabrication de locomotives électriques
et diesel électrique à belfort il ya 13
cents personnes l usine de table il y en
à peu près autant toutes ces personnes
ne participe à des degrés divers à la
réalisation des machines les uns
discutant avec le client pour définir la
locomotive les autres faisant les études
techniques et définissant les plans des
machines et ensuite dans les usines les
différentes professions soudeur
chaudronnier câbleur essayeur participe
à la réalisation des machines qui
finalement parts sur le propre route
belfort et quels types de machines
fabriquées vous il y a deux grandes
familles de locomotive construite à
belfort il ya les locomotives
électriques et les locomotives
diesel-électriques locomotives
électriques nécessite la présence de
caténaire pour pouvoir se déplacer sur
les voies alors que les machines diesel
électrique peuvent au pied levé
remplacer les machines à vapeur sur
n'importe quelle voix quels sont vos
clients
et combien de lecouls fabriquez-vous en
une année en moyenne nous fabriquons
entre 130 et 170 locomotive par an nous
avons à peu près la moitié de cette
production qui est destiné à la sncf
l'autre moitié par à peu près dans tous
les pays du monde à l'heure actuelle par
exemple nous travaillons pour la grèce
pour la tunisie où madagascar pour
l'ethiopie l'année prochaine il
est vraisemblable que nous travaillerons
également pour la colombie est peut-être
pour quelques pays d'asie
bon laissons monsieur fromager directeur
de la traction en grande conversation et
jette un coup d'oeil dans les bureaux de
dessin
si l'on a décidé de ma naissance à paris
c'est ici que dans la mise en forme le
projet retouches en modifiant sans cesse
chacun de mes organes
mais je n'ai vraiment commencé à naître
qu'à l'instant où j'ai quitté la table à
dessin
dans le fracas des machines tout a
débuté peu à peu par petits morceaux
éparpillés aux quatre coins de cet
immense mal j'ai commencé à vivre
ce sont les hommes qui m'ont fait avec
des machines bien sûr mais aussi avec
cet amour que les artisans porte au
travail bien fait
oui avec amour chacun m'a donné ma forme
ont l'élégance ma vitesse la solidité et
dans chacun de leurs gestes
les hommes de l'atelier de la direction
avait déjà de l'amitié de la fierté
actuaire l'écart des hommes et des
femmes se sont longuement penchés sur
des circuits y embrouillée de file car
il ne s'agit pas de me faire faire une
fausse manoeuvre
n'oubliez pas que je pèse 120 tonnes et
coûte la bagatelle d'autant de millions
dans un autre atelier les grandes
plaques taux longs étaient courbés
grignoter galbées soudé et la caisse a
pris forme et l'acier devenu robot j je
me suis vu devenir une belle machine au
profil étudié fait deux lignes pures et
là encore la main de l'homme a fait tout
ce qu'il fallait
afin que demain je sois rapide solide
souple et belle
le puissant moteur vous voyez ce diesel
il fait trois mille 600 chevaux
il vient de l' essentiel de mulhouse a
été fixé à sa place au centre de mon
châssis est doucement je me suis avancée
vers la sortie vers la lumière
l'électricien a tendu des kilomètres de
câbles cause obéissent aux
sollicitations les plus précises dans
une eau qu il ya de 10 à 15 km de fils
électriques
le p2 chargé de mai ressort à contrôler
la réaction de la souplesse
et comme on le faisait quand mes grands
mères à vapeur il ya 60 ans presque au
même endroit de l'atelier des
techniciens habile au millimètre près en
quelques secondes on déposait mac est
terminée sur ses rails
combien de locaux vous faites par mois
ici au match en moyenne 14 automotive
par mois et combien de personnes
travaillent environ six cents 600
personnes en tant que chaudronnier
soudeur peintre et monteur et combien
faut-il des travailleurs et comme le dit
le temps pour faire une locaux en
moyenne il faut deux mois de préparation
puisque trois mois de
2 pour les gros éléments et rend chez
nous en avons sans compter les essais
s'en vont réaliser simplement
chaudronnerie et après la machine avec
la peinture elle repart aux essais pour
la peinture c'est une autre histoire
ma toilette est délicate et les peintres
sont des artistes il faut me passer à la
peinture et le cuir aux infrarouges six
fois pour que ma robe résiste au soleil
et aux hivers de tous les pays du monde
mes robes sont différentes selon les
pays où je vais dans les pays d'afrique
et d'asie
les couleurs sont claires tendre pastel
rehaussé de ceintures aux tons vifs pour
les pays d'europe
je suis plus sévère d'apparence je porte
des bleus des verts et des rails et
sombre
toute belle je me hisse sur un pont
transbordeur et l'on m'apporte devant le
bâtiment destiné aux effets apporte fixe
c'est là dans ce coin isolé de lusine
qu'un technicien va éprouver les
qualités de mon moteur
la précision de mes réactions la
justesse de ma puissance
l' équilibre de mon cerveau
et doucement je suis venu sur la voie
d'essai ou comme mes soeurs je pourrais
donner le meilleur de moi même et c'est
dû mais fera mon accélération la
stabilité sur une voie spécialement
aménagée le long des usines sur 1 km 500
la suite vous la connaissez
elle débute sur ce matin l'été 1955
et je suis devenue championne du monde
de vitesse si mon nom à pénétrer jusque
dans la moindre chaumières c'est à tous
ceux de l'alstom que je le dois aux
ingénieurs aux employés aux ouvriers
belfortain ils ont continué le long
travail destiné à améliorer depuis le
début du siècle les performances du rail
et
les déjà d'autres voyages m'attendent
alors comme au bon vieux temps disons en
voiture au revoir
e